cuz I mean let's just be honest you're
you're absolutely
ripped right I don't you're hammered
it's pretty clear that you you've been
drinking you appear very intoxicated
right now so were you like pass out or
something I know that's why it wasn't
You' been drinking tonight sir I'm a
captain Police Department what Police
Department oklah
City from judges to police captains to
State reps we're breaking down the top
six times officials got allegedly busted
for DUI welcome to after hours presented
by law and crime I'm Sam
Goldberg first we're in Brimfield
Township Ohio where 55-year-old County
Judge Rebecca Dy finds herself inside
the local police station earlier that
evening body cam captures the moment
officers approach the judge's crashed
SUV man' you've got vomit down here on
your door3 deal after being put in the
back of the police car Dy becomes
hysterical absolutely out of my mind
with the judge is then taken into
booking where she begins making demands
let me call liberg have a seat no
Rebecca listen this whole thing is being
recorded do not do something you are
going to regret tomorrow do me a favor
and have a seat so we can do our job I'm
not going to call anybody yet okay we
have stuff we have to do will you please
have a seat you're trying to walk out
the door and you're almost falling down
can you please have a seat falling
have a Paul Larry limberg Rebecca I will
put you in one of the cells if you do
I'm trying play nice with you have a
seat call in
now now after some contemplation in a
Cell the judge now has other
requests what can I do for you drink
water we just literally told you 10
seconds ago that we're getting you a
drink of water he's off the front right
now getting you the glass not 10 seconds
ago I went drink of water now thank
you now I contacted your daughter she's
arranging transportation for you home
tell my daughter I already did no my
daughter is not the issue call Larry
lber I tried him he didn't answer really
do you want the water the water yeah I
do okay Larry lber
okay Larry
lber judge Dy was later charged with
operating a vehicle while under the
influence of alcohol and sentenced to
180 days in jail which was later reduced
to 3 days her driver's license was also
suspended a year your phone is in a
puddle of vomit and your car which is on
the side of can I finish which is on the
side of the road that you crashed into
yes the tow company is out there trying
to get it out however it is extremely
snowy and slippery out they are not able
to get the vehicle out so far so your
phone is off the table right now we
don't have access to it
next we head to Oklahoma City where a
police captain finds himself on the
wrong end of a body camera back in your
car I'm drunk no I'm a captain huh
Captain a what
captain of what the B don't reach in
your pocket get back in your
car you've been drinking tonight I just
got a ride you've been drinking tonight
sir I'm my captain on Police Department
what Police Department Oklahoma
City it's Captain James French of the
Oklahoma City Police Department to be
exact French had been with the
department for more than 30 years how
much we had to drink tonight
sir please
huh I'm not turning my camera off the
responding officer has the drunk police
captain steep out of his vehicle you go
to be kidding
me while the body cam was still rolling
Captain French agrees to a sobriety
test turn that off I cannot sir please I
know you're aware of a body cam policy
you know I cannot turn off this body cam
but I'd like talk to
you I can't do that sir please
please I like talk to
you are you going to do the test or not
will you please talk to me I'll talk to
you once we you can turn it off you can
turn it on I can turn it off once I'm
done with my investigations
okay I'm asking you I'm a captain on
Poli I understand that sir and I am a
sergeant on this police officer and not
taking to uphold the law I don't show
favoritism to anyone regardless I don't
care if you're a gang banger or the
president of the United States sir I'm
not asking you for that Captain French
is then arrested and taken into
custody go ahead and turn around for me
put your hands behind your back are you
going to arrest me sir yes I
am can I talk to you going put your
hands behind your back
Sir
[Music]
camera off now French was booked on
driving under the influence of alcohol
and has been placed on administrative
leave next we're in Prescott Arizona
where another judge was stopped by
police you know I'm a judge here you are
yeah okay
and for y County yes I don't want to use
that I don't want to use it I don't okay
uh I really don't I really don't this is
Yavapai County Superior Court Judge sule
Hancock police officers caught up with
her after there were reports that
someone was acting erratically at a
Safeway grocery store what's going on
today
ma'am okay well we got some reports that
you were inside of Safeway yes and
you're walking around stumbling and you
got back in your
vehicle and you left the
store
and now you're
here okay do me a favor and turn off
your car so I can hear
you
perfect so my next question to you Ma'am
is have you been drinking today you
haven't been drinking today okay are you
having a medical condition today or
medical issue
get okay so would there be a reason that
somebody would call and say that maybe
you're stumbling around in Safe
Way okay I I I'm just trying to get my
okay so why'd you leave your wallet at
the
store trying to get my prescription M
okay Hancock told the officer she was at
the pharmacy to pick up a prescription
for a seizure
disorder while keeping both legs
straight point the toe of your raised
foot down look at the raised foot keep
your arms to your side it's going to
look like this and you're going to pick
one foot hands down to your side D did
you ask did you ask her do you have bad
ankles I have bad feet bad ankles I
everything okay how about those shoes
are they pretty comfortable
shoes I'm just asking yes okay right and
out of both of your legs which leg is
the most uh they're both bad okay which
one is not not as bad they're both bad
okay okay so it's your choice what like
you're going to raise okay okay it's
either the left or the right bad okay
they're all they're both bad okay okay
and your
toe what am
I when's the time you
started it's already
started things then go from bad to worse
when Hancock does a breathalyzer test
and blows a0
219 this hand yeah you mind step on the
vehicle for me please
okay do me a favor go ahead and turn
around and put your hands behind your
back please all right place you underr
for driving Under Suspicion uh DUI I'm
going to have you go in the back of my
car which is just behind us okay but I'm
going to put the cuffs on first all
right then we're going to go back to my
station and do a few more tests okay and
then at that point once we are done with
a test we'll have a your friend who came
here earlier and pick you up okay
despite telling multiple off officers
that she's a judge Hancock also says she
wants to be treated like a quote normal
person them I'm a judge here so oh okay
well I apparently I apologize I've never
met you it's good that you never I'm
up so they're making phone calls and we
we just figure out what what we do after
this okay so again you've been very
sweet and appreciate
that
up
and it shouldn't mean
anything you just a person like
everybody else just a normal person like
everybody else I'm just a normal person
like it shouldn't matter that's okay um
we're going to go we're just going to
have you sit in my in my patrol car for
now okay get you out of the weather just
so you're not getting water on you the r
don't treat me like video Hancock was
charged with what's known in Arizona as
as an extreme DUI she later took a plea
deal and spent one day in jail and paid
a fine of
$1,650 now we're in kalamazo County
Michigan where this time it's the
sheriff who's in some hot water so what
happened the next sir I know all I know
I wanted to get you I don't have no clue
I that's Mark Lily white the sheriff of
St Joseph County Michigan it's February
26th 2023 around 3:00 a.m. and Lily has
just crashed his car while driving drunk
at nearly 100
mph whose car is this that's a Count's
car County's car okay so and then I'm I
got you I got you so you don't know
who's driving the county car that you're
riding passenger in be
Hest I I'm bad bad bad but no I don't
okay I listen to me
okay who so who was it I have no idea
body camera shows Lily white in the
passenger seat of his car despite there
being no one else at the scene Lily
white insists he wasn't the one driving
what happened before you went into the
ditch no I
was okay I didn't ask that I asked what
happened before you went into the ditch
who was driving I'm cold I'm cold too
I'm out here with you who uh who was
driving I have no idea it's pretty clear
that you you've been drinking you appear
very intoxicated right now so were you
like pass out or something I know that's
why I
wasn't I got you but were you sir you
you were sleeping or you just weren't
paying attention or what no I waset I
have no idea after Lily white refuses to
do any field sobriety tests or take a
breathalyzer the trooper takes the
sheriff into custody a blood draw at the
hospital showed his blood alcohol level
was .25 more than three times the legal
limit to drive Lily white who had been
in law enforcement for three decades
pleaded guilty to two misdemeanor
operating while intoxicated and carrying
a weapon while under the influence of
alcohol at the time of this recording
Lily white is still the sheriff of St
Joseph County next we're staying in
Michigan where it's not just Law
Enforcement Officers driving drunk It's
allegedly firefighters too Dearborn Fire
Chief Joseph Murray has spoken out
before Against Drunk Driving but on
August 29th 2023 he was is the one
arrested on suspicion of DUI leg see how
my leg straight toes pointed like this
see like that oh oh my gosh we're not
going to do that bum police pulled
Murray over after Murray was going 60 M
hour the speed limit was only
40 hello aler pointed General Police
Department do you have any idea how fast
we going today uh to fast I apologize
before they start testing to see if he's
Intoxicated The off officer wants to
know if the fire chief has had anything
to drink said anything to drink tonight
sir yeah I I've had a couple of VI for
sure how many beers a couple beers uh
um three or four three or four yeah okay
how long ago did you have those what's
that how long ago did you have those
beers
uh I within a couple hours all right
what time do you think it is right now
sir without looking at the clock you
already looked at the clock Sor you're
good all right have you had anything to
drink or eat in the last 15
minutes uh in the last 15 minutes yep no
okay so go ahead and shut the vehicle
off for me yes sir go and step out of
the vehicle things don't get much better
when Murray gets out of the car cuz I
mean let's just be honest you're you're
absolutely
ried right I don't you're hammered drunk
you can barely speak you can barely
stand
up
can come on over the field sobriety
tests don't go well with Murray losing
his balance and having trouble following
what the officer is saying when it comes
time to do a breathalyzer Murray
requests a lawyer I mean no I I'm like
I'm for a lawyer or something you don't
want to take that I don't understand
like what's you just want to see where
you're at because I think you're
intoxicated I think you've had too much
to drink today this will just kind of
give us a rough estimate of exactly
where kind of that numberers at okay I
feel like I feel like I just need to
wait for a lawyer you want to wait for a
lawyer fantastic you're going to be
placed under arrest put your hands
behind your back okay under arrest for
drunk driving Murray was later arrested
and released the department placed him
on administrative leave and as of this
recording Murray has not been officially
charged next we head to Nassau County
Florida where County Commissioner Aaron
Bell was arrested in June 2022 for DUI
he must see your license registration
Pro
urance I have no license I'm sorry I
don't have my license you don't have
your license no I don't do you have a
bid license yes you don't have it with
you no okay all right according to
Bell's arrest report police got a call
about a reckless driver the officer
stopped Bell who allegedly had a strong
smell of alcohol on his breath and
appeared disoriented so how much have
you had to drink today as far as alcohol
goes okay I don't believe you neither
does he no I I but can you get me home
no no that's please no MM no why are you
different than anybody else I stop and
do a DUI investigation with because of
who your wife is don't work that way bud
don't work that way okay you're not
privileged because of what your wife
does for a living of course not okay
according to the arrest report Bell
failed various roadside sobriety tests
after refusing a breathalyzer test
police say Bell then requested to go to
the hospital even though he couldn't
tell paramedics what exactly was wrong
Bell was brought to the hospital by his
own request medically cleared and then
taken to the Nassau County jail he was
later charged with driving under the
influence our last stop is in Seymour
Indiana hi over here I recognize you
what's your name Jim Lucas Jim Lucas
officials say on May 31st Lucas crashed
his car about an hour South of
Indianapolis he allegedly hit two guard
rails then made a u-turn which meant he
was going the wrong way down an exit
ramp when police finally caught up with
Lucas the State Rep claims he was just
out walking out for a walk M
okay you didn't see a van go by with no
tires on it I no van no van okay all
right I mean you've been drinking so
that's why we're I'm asking you because
we got somebody that's apparently
driving around with no tires on a van
and then we got you stumbling around out
here I have no
van
okay 110 come over here
hang tight Jim all right eventually
Lucas is arrested all right Jim you have
the right to remain silent anything you
say can will be used against you in
quarter law you have the right to
consult with the lawyer before answering
questions and to have a lawyer with you
during any questioning if you cannot
afford to hire a lawyer one will be
provided for you free of cost is so
desire one do you understand regie okay
do you still want to talk to us I'm
sorry I do not you do not okay in a move
we've seen before Lucas asks the officer
to turn off his body camera is your
camera on yes it's always on y turn off
say something I okay you up by
not by not checking me I volunteered my
way yeah well I didn't have to check you
yet and plus I was standing with you now
but but
you I'm not arguing I know you I had a
weapon right if I were a bad guy right I
had the
advantage yes I know no I'm trained I
didn't say you weren't no no no I and
I'm not arguing that right but you don't
know that I'm not I know that I always I
I don't I don't um and see here's the
thing okay I I am the biggest supporter
of 2A rights same everybody has a right
same okay in situation like this you
also have a right to be suspicious once
the officers get Lucas into a vehicle
they mention the smell of alcohol on his
breath spell anything on them oh yeah I
can spell it that's I want to get in my
car
yeah so they're just down there U my
corpor is right there so he'll let you
know
too yep you're good Lucas pleaded guilty
to two misdemeanor charges and received
a 60-day suspended sentence for the
charge of operating a vehicle while
intoxicated and a 180 days suspended
sentence for leaving the scene where he
hit the guard rail he later took a plea
deal and had to pay $4,000 for the
damage to the guardrail spent a year on
probation and complete a drug and
alcohol program for Law and Crime After
Hours I'm Sam
Goldberg my mom and I stay here you been
drinking